Very likely you're gonna
make quite a few mistakes.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here, and
today I want to talk about something
a little different as it relates to
language learning and that is reward
yourself in your language learning.
It's gonna help you remember.
If you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for more
uh, notifications and if you
follow me on a podcast service,
uh, please leave a comment.
So the biggest problem that people
have in language learning is that they
give up, they get frustrated, they
don't feel that they're making any
progress, and they stop continuing to
listen and read and study the language.
And I think there are a number of things
that we can do to maintain our motivation,
but one of them is to reward yourself.
Like I decided to go back to Turkish.
So I was listening to
Turkish while out for a walk.
And while I've now forgotten a lot
of my Turkish I recognized that I
hear the words very, very clearly.
I don't know necessarily what
the words mean, but I hear them.
So in any, whenever we're learning a
language, when we're at a stage where
we hear the words clearly, where word
ends and the next word begins, and,
and we kind of notice that word very
clearly, we just have to look it up.
We don't know what it means, or
we've forgotten what it means,
I give myself credit for that.
I say, yeah, wow.
You know, it's gonna be fun
relearning Turkish because
I hear the words so clearly.
I have mentioned before that we shouldn't,
you know, get upset when we forget things
or when we, um, are unable to say things
or when we don't understand things.
It, it's far better to reward ourselves
for the things that we are able to do.
And, and that's something that we are able
to do, should be something that's a little
difficult to do 'casue it's a, if it's a
little difficult to do and we can reward
ourselves, the brain actually likes that.
Apparently there's, you know, research
that talks about this being, you
know, in the zone and attempting to do
something that's a little difficult,
but actually being able to carry if off.
We have that sense of
achievement, we are encouraged.
The brain is...
gets, I don't know, a shot of endorphins
or whatever and wants to do more of that.
So it's important to reward yourself.
Unfortunately, traditional
language instruction works more
on the principle of penalizing us.
So we have a test, we're gonna
test what was just taught.
The teacher's gonna test you.
Very likely you're gonna
make quite a few mistake.
As you're doing this test, you're
almost reluctant to answer the
question because there's a high
likelihood you're gonna get it wrong.
That's one thing, by the way that I like
about the matching pairs that we have
now in the new version that I'm testing
on iOS, and which will eventually be
available on all our platforms, that
you can get it wrong and very quickly,
you know, okay oh, that one isn't right.
So, You know, maybe these
are the pairs that match.
In other words, do things in a
way that you're easily rewarded
and not so easily knocked down.
Because I think maintaining our motivation
is so important, and we have to bear
in mind that the process of learning a
language is one of, it's a slow process.
First of all, we shouldn't have
expectations that we're gonna learn
anything very quickly, and it's sort
of like peeling layers of an onion or
I've compared it to a jigsaw puzzle.
Slowly, slowly things become,
you know, clearer to us.
So if at first, I, I hear the divisions,
you know, where a word ends and where
the next word begins, but I don't know
what the words mean but still, I can
accept that as a step in the right
direction, wherever it's possible to
say, good, you know, you did that.
That's why we have our statistics, so
that when we're in that long period
where we don't have the impression that
we're improving, at least the statistics
tell me that I've been active and I've
created LingQs and I've read so many
words, and I've listened to so many
hours because I know personally that
if I am active, then I will learn.
That's the advantage of this idea
of having a challenge where you're
trying to maintain your streak.
Because even though you may not feel
you've improved that day, at least if you
maintained your streak, you did something.
You're rewarding yourself
for your level of activity.
Because even though learning a
language is a slow process, if
you stay with it, if you remain
active, you are going to improve.
Even though very often you don't
really feel that you're improving.
So my, the main message today is
reward yourself for what you can do.
Don't criticize yourself for
what you're not capable of doing.
There will be many moments when you
perhaps disappoint yourself and you
shouldn't, you know, emphasize that
sort of disappointment or frustration.
You should give your credit.
Give yourself credit for things that
you are doing, whether it is hearing
something, whether it is, you know,
if you're studying Russian and you
notice more and more, you're seeing the
letter that we think is P acts as an
R, you know, in the Cyrillic alphabet.
All of these things that seem
frustratingly difficult to do, not
because they're difficult, but because
our brain isn't getting used to it.
And wherever we have an opportunity
to recognize that we have stepped
forward, taken a step forward, or
at least that our, uh, statistics at
LingQ show us that we have been active,
we should say, we should accept the
credit for that you're doing well.
And this might sound sort of
silly, you know, how very often
now in kids sporting events, they
want to give everybody a prize.
It's not a matter of
giving everybody a prize.
Obviously if you have a race, somebody
came first, second, and third.
But language learning isn't a race.
Language learning is a long,
uh, long distance run where
you have to develop stamina.
And one thing that's gonna feed that
stamina is giving yourself credit
for what you're doing, what you're
achieving, and how active you are.
Okay, so, so let's have a look at how
these statistics might be motivating.
So I decided to put a
little effort into Turkish.
So over the last three days I've
been doing quite a bit of listening.
So I may not have the sense that I've
necessarily improved a lot, but I see
that I've put a lot of effort into
listening in the language and I reminding
myself of this level of activity.
It's rewarding if I check, uh, you
know, words of reading, I'll also see
that I've read, you know, 1,800 words.
Um, this is, you know, you need
to remind yourself that being
active is gonna get you there.
Obviously if I look at, you know,
this month, I'll see that all this
activities in the last few days, but
if I get back to the last seven days,
and if I look at um LingQs created.
I've also been active, so
it is just a minor thing.
You know, my coins, I'm exceeding my
daily, albeit a very modest daily target.
Uh, I have on occasion when I've
been in a, a challenge, I've set
a much more demanding target.
I've set a target of,
let's say, 400 coins.
A.
Uh, which is then tough.
You've gotta work to, to, to hit that.
The a hundred coins is very easy to hit.
You know, create a few
links, a few LingQs, listen a
little bit, and you're there.
So, uh, just to show you that
there are ways you can use, uh,
your statistics at LingQ to remind
yourself that you are being active.
And if you believe, and you
should believe that if you're
active, you're gonna improve, then
that should be, uh, motivating.
And, uh, before I end the video,
I thought I would direct you to
a couple of videos that I did on
related subjects not so long ago.
Uh, one talks about motivation,
uh, how to stay motivated, and the
other talks about frustrations.
And obviously if we can reward
ourselves, we can stay motivated
and we can avoid frustration.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.